hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video back on for on her and today we
have some more news to talk about with
the most recent dead stream it was a
slow news day again but there was a
little bit more info as opposed to last
week's video so as always like the B if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
covered the leaks the informational side
of foreign or patch notes bound changes
new updates all the type of stuff and
with that let's get started now as I
said this is going to be a slow news day
today like I said nothing too crazy but
that's because the Ubisoft III
conference is going to be on June 11th
which is this upcoming Monday so which
as everyone knows which will come with
tons of info on future content with
foreign oarsmen as well as many other
things in the next dev stream as well
which will go into more detail I'm
assuming on the info being talked about
at e3 so e3 is gonna be kind of like a
vague kind of statement saying oh we're
gonna have like let's say for example
this AR we're gonna have this hero but
in the next step stream they're gonna go
more in depth of what the hero has
customization moveset maybe stuff like
that of course this is all just
speculation but that's what I'm going to
assume is going to happen next if you
happen to get any XP boost tickets don't
worry this was a 100% intentional these
are just tickets that they give you an
XP boost instead of wasting your Salvage
you can get these tickets by having a
hero from rep 1 to rep 49 so if you have
three heroes between rep 1 and rep 49
you're going to get 3 tickets I'm
unaware if this is still a thing but I'd
give it a try and if you use it you can
use it on the double xp upcoming up and
coming to get those heroes to at least
rep one speaking of double xp there's
going to be an XP fest which I've stated
multiple times in celebration of III
going from June 11th to June 18 so all
of next week which will give you tons of
time to rank up your characters whether
it be new or old heroes on top of the
double xp you can pair that with the
revamp champions that is to get you tons
of XP and an XP boost before every game
so that you can be maximizing out the
amount of XP you give for the entire
week and just start going up in reps
daily there's also going to be a
community event where we have to get as
many executions as possible in tribute
and then we'll get 2000 still if you
participate and then next up they showed
the roadmap for the June and July which
I will show on screen and there really
wasn't much to look at except that dance
of death is coming back on July 5th and
there will be a patch 1.25 coming out in
June 28th which may or may not have some
good changes we don't know yet maybe
we'll find out soon and the devs
mentioned that there might be news that
will be on the roadmap but they can't
show just yet so it's probably going to
be talked about in III or next week
stream so we'll have to wait and see
what that info
is next up is the content of the weekend
this is faction based effects which as
stated is a different change depending
on your faction of the character the
Knights have roses the Vikings have
these white flowers and the samurai have
nice bright colored flowers if there's
any botanist watching you can inform it
with the actual names that these flowers
are but I'm just going to base them just
off the color and because next we show
is gonna be all about the e3 stuff they
might as well have showed us a photo for
the upcoming new week of content and
that's going to be elite outfits now
these personally don't look too bad for
me
but personally I'm going to be saving my
steel for some other things maybe
whatever they happen to be talking about
it III so that's entirely up to you and
that's it guys like I said small news
day today but with tons of info coming
this upcoming Monday and then the
Thursday after that which I will recap
for all of you just that we can all be
informed on what they're going to be
talking about I'm very excited in the
comments below I want you guys to let me
know what you guys think they're gonna
be talking about III I know they showed
that one teaser trailer we covered but
on top of that what else are they gonna
show whether it be maps a new guy a new
game-mode new map and you anything new
character new something or maybe just
some reworks or whatever you guys think
that they're going to show I'd love to
hear your thoughts and what you think
they'll show at e3 this upcoming Monday
and talk about on the dev stream on
Thursday what that like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if we knew like I said I
covered the balance changes for 400 that
being but what that like the V if you
did enjoy subscribe if you're new like I
said I covered the informational side of
fallen or that being balanced changes
new updates new leaks new move sets for
characters anything new update wise
patch notes all that stuff I like the
cover and my two most recent videos will
be on screen if you guys want to check
that out went that guy is sober
yesterday thank for watching the video
peace out